hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guest today is photographer michael
muller michael is one of the most
in-demand commercial photographers in
the world
he's created the billboards and
posters and campaigns for many a
blockbuster movie
he shot with all kinds of top brands and
he also
spends a tremendous amount of his time
resources and energy
documenting sharks for shark
preservation
he's devoted to causes around the
environment
and many other fascinating
deep dives that we go into today from
ptsd
to virtual reality to cleaning up the
plastics
in the oceans we talk about creativity
and many other subjects
if you enjoy the video content that we
work hard to create please hit that
subscribe button and that little
notification bell
thank you very much and without further
ado this is me
and michael muller
[Music]
so i feel like we just had a whole
experience together
before the podcast the experience we had
we tried to get the vr working the shark
vr thing
we might be able to get it working mid
podcast in which case we'll take a break
but
i really wanted to see that before we
talked today technology
i gotta love it right it's crazy well i
was just saying like
yeah the whole oculus thing is at a
certain point where
it's amazing but also not super user
friendly
it's kind of janky right well i'd say
this
if your sons or my daughters were here
you'd be watching yeah
right
yeah i don't know if it's the tech or
just us but yeah i mean you know
that's why apple's been so successful in
my opinion simple
yeah easy to use the user interface is
always
super intuitive yeah whenever i'm making
like websites and stuff i
tell the developers and even add clients
i'm like
people are they're not dumb but they're
impatient
like you got to be you know when they go
to a site or something you got to be
able to
get to it real quick yeah you're trying
to figure stuff out
you leave i know and at like 53 forget
about it
you know right that ship is sailed so
leave it to the kids well
listen man i'm uh i'm so excited to have
you here i've wanted to talk to you
and meet you for a really long time so
thank you for coming out i appreciate it
man
my pleasure um this morning i woke up
and i
opened up twitter and i hit the discover
tab
to see what the news was and the number
one trending story this morning
was a shark attack on the gold coast did
you see that
no i was about to make a couple jokes in
my head i was like
yeah it could have political jokes but
just going on
firing but that actually makes my point
even more strong which is
that you know the shark attack will
always be the number one story despite
all the craziness going on in the world
right now
that's the number one story and what got
buried in that because i was reading
about it
um surfer you know attacked lost his
life
but it was the first shark attack
like on that whole coastline in like
over a decade
well it was like a couple weeks ago
because i was just like i went to the
hamptons a couple weeks on the east
coast
and that everyone was talking about
because the woman you know uh
got killed a couple weeks back first
time
ever a shark attack you know this guy
that you're talking about
got attacked lost his life or whatever
but if you look
you know it's first time in 10 years
probably before that
that might have been the first one like
the numbers are so
right out of whack so the one thing you
always say is like yeah when you we
we're all terrified
of shark attacks i swim in the ocean all
the time open water swimming and
everyone is always like what about
sharks what about sharks
yeah you have to bear it in mind but the
thing that you always say is
there that we're killing a hundred
something like a hundred million sharks
a year
yeah and that's probably and how many
shark attacks are there right here so
well there's five deaths worldwide on
average
five five five and you think about the
probably trillions of people that are in
the ocean
in that year trillions not you know um
what i do because i'll i'll be out
surfing you know out here in point doom
especially if it's like a gray cloudy
day by myself or
you know only one other guy out and i'll
get the heebie-jeebies
because i'm playing you know when you're
under when i'm diving i can see the
sharks like i know my environment
yes here when you're on the surface you
don't know what's that's that's when
they have that's
the fear because you can't see anything
and that deep
which is what led me to sharks to begin
with that deep you know ingrained fear
that i have of this animal come in and
attack me i'm like oh i can feel like
i'll have the heebie-jeebies like i can
feel a shark in the area
i'm going to get attacked it's going to
bite my leg right now
and what i've learned to do this is my
trick to get that to go away is i go
okay
i am more likely to win the super lotto
twice this month not once twice
more likely for that to happen than for
a shark to attack me
right now and when i do those those
facts
it goes away and i'm like okay it's you
know it's not gonna happen yeah but jaws
well and if it does you know what i mean
like if a shark does attack me
and if i die so be i'd much rather die
by great white death
than by cancer or any of the other
seriously i mean you know what i mean
like it's going to be quick and
uh it'll be a good story to sort of let
go and let the thing chomp and i'm going
to help the circle of life and i'm going
to feed this animal that's going to be
i don't know just acceptance of if
that's the way to go it actually is not
that bad of a way to go i don't think
compare
comparatively speaking do you know uh
paul to gelder
yes yeah yeah yeah i've had him on the
show he's a buddy
and it's just so cool that somebody who
literally almost lost his life as a
result of that
has now devoted it to the preservation
of the animal that almost
killed him mike coogs bethany you can go
down the list of shark attack victims
pretty much 99 of them are always gonna
seem to always come out the other side
supporting the sharks
conservation you know i'm not i'm not
you know i don't blame the shark
right rarely do you see someone that
like lost their leg and they're like i
hate sharks i want to kill them all like
i haven't seen that yet on the news when
they see these it's a weird thing
right that somebody who was almost
killed by this animal then
develops like a love affair with it well
how many dogs how many people died by
you know dogs this year seriously
icicles icicles kill
670 people a year
not kidding you falling from mostly in
russia
but 670 people die from icicle death an
exponentially
higher number than shark dust way higher
there's there's soda machine stats too
you know how many people die by soda
machines
that's a weird one i heard that recently
they tip over on people
exactly more than more than sharks so
you should be scared when you're getting
a soda much more than
jaws so you mentioned the fear
was that like a conscious thing like i'm
afraid of sharks so i'm going to move
towards this
it was you know jaws it was a
combination of jaws
growing up surfing in northern
california where the waters are
populated by great whites i mean they
would attack a seal with surfers out and
everyone would go in and watch the
shark and the blood in the water and two
hours later you know go back out and
surf again
yeah so i just had that fear and about
15 16 years ago i'm like you know what i
don't want to
i want to see a great way i want to
photograph one i want to go see like i
want to face it like i'm
and started saying because of the fear
or was that like the
adventure impulse it was sort of both
you know i started diving at 10 years
old in the persian gulf i grew up in
saudi arabia for four years and it was
like untouched reefs
um actually the first sort of photograph
when i saw the power of photography i
took a picture
of a picture of a shark with my
waterproof camera at like 11
and developed the film and then showed
my buddies and told them i had taken it
right like no way and then i had to like
say all right it wasn't me it was not
geo but
i saw their reaction but the power of
the image to inspire yeah and so
early you know i started talking about
my wife for my birthday got me one of
those cards good for one short
trip you know which previously i'd never
collected
the race car or anything the next day i
went down and signed up
went down to guadalupe first one in the
water six in the morning
still dark out was that the the iwc
campaign or yeah
that was it this was the first trip by
myself and i was the first one the cage
and that shirt came up five minutes in
the water comes up out of the darkness
swims by
and where you are about that far from me
and we locked eyes just like i'm doing
with you
and my life changed i was like oh i
see you you see me you're not this
mindless killing machine
like it just from that moment and on
that trip i was like hanging out of the
cage by my waist
and you know it's just like god i'd love
to be out there but i still you know had
a fear
and at the same time i was shooting
michael phelps and all the
olympians i was doing the speedo
campaign which i did for like nine years
in a row
and a sort of combination of the two
things i was like i wanna
i wanna light a shark like i do iron man
like i want to edge light it and studio
light it well i can't bring the shark
to the studio i got to bring the studio
to the sharks so i went online
figuring there would be lights they
didn't exist it was 400 watt and then
big movie lights
so long story short and then i could
also do that with the swimmers and you
know
surfing and all type stuff they didn't
exist so i set out to invent them i'm
like well i'm gonna have to make them
and you know that's where fear comes in
in that place too like
who are you to make a light how are
you're not going to be able to make you
know all
that chatter starts happening but you
know
one thing led to another met one guy who
you know met a guy actually got ripped
off and i almost gave up and then i met
this guy who looked at me he was like i
can do it
and i believed that he believed he could
and i'm like all right well i'll give
you a little bit of the money
and then when you deliver i'll pay you
at all we got a guy from nasa a guy from
jpl
jet propulsion laboratories and we
actually made
the most powerful underwater strobe
light it's a pro photo basically
and i received four or five patents on
them
and iwc the president was in town
and i was putting their watches on
celebrities and so
they came up to my house and i showed
him that one short trip
the one trip that i'd done i told him
about these lights that i'm making
and he gave me their aqua timer campaign
on the spot which was like nine months
ahead
and all of his employees looked at him
like you're giving
this hollywood portrait guy our
underwater campaign and you know at the
time i'm not david dubois or one of
these
award-winning underwater guys and i'm
like i'm going to crush this so i'm
going to have these lights and
everything
mind you the lights didn't exist at that
point the day before we left to the
galapagos
the lights arrived i jumped in my pool
fired them they worked
and i went down to the galapagos very
naive i'd done one short trip
didn't really know any of the statistics
and we were with unesco and the charles
darwin foundation
and that's where i got educated on what
was happening to our planet this is you
know 15 years ago
we were killing 100 million sharks half
the great barrier reef was gone at the
time now it's 60
so we've already lost 10 in the last 15
years
and all the other things right right
yeah it's so interesting i mean this is
clearly you're you do lots of stuff but
this is
you know your primary passion and it
seems
you know in contrast to the other work
that you do but when you understand your
full story
like looking backwards you know vision
is always 20 20 it seems to make perfect
sense right
you're taking all of this studio cred
and all the acumen that you've developed
over the years like working with
celebrities and these movie campaigns
and commercial campaigns
and then bringing that to the natural
environment to like
light these sharks underwater to create
these
images that are truly like iconic i mean
i was just looking at your book right
now it's just stunning
well that's sort of on that trip i went
up to the roof of the boat one night and
the stars were out
and i said to myself i have three
daughters and i look i said i don't
think
my kids are gonna be able to see some of
this stuff you know the whale sharks i
was seeing and the schools the
hammerhead
uh and you know i still had that fear
right so i went from one cage dive with
great whites down with no cages and
hundreds of hammerhead sharks and
galapagos sharks you know and like i
sort of got thrown into it
but i said you know i don't think
they're going to see this so i made a
decision
and that's i think anything in life it
starts with that decision
you know i'm going to start biking or
whatever it is i'm going to
you know create an app that's going to
change the world right so i made this
decision that i'm going to do everything
i could
to help sharks that was the of all the
issues in the ocean i'm going to help
sharks and do everything i can to raise
as much awareness
as much money uh to help this animal
that's been so
misconstrued construed by movies and
news and
the idea for that book hit me that on
that trip at that same time i'm like i'm
gonna do a book
and i saw the sharks coming out of light
because i hadn't taken the lights yet
and gone to do
great whites or anything and i'm like if
people see a shark in a way they've
never seen them before it's going to
make them stop and look
and then i can educate them and i'm like
i want to do a passion book
you know this is 10 years before i got
the tasha
you know the idea that seed at least in
my life i see it so i'm like all right
i'm gonna do a book
and it's gonna come in a cage and all
this stuff and it might take a decade
but as long as i'm walking towards that
vision
it usually manifests right it's amazing
how powerful
our minds are to you know bend reality
and manifest
you know what we want in our lives which
in my in my opinion or
you know for me it was to help our
planet and help help this next
generation yeah and by picking a very
specific thing to focus on
you can have more impact than just being
like hey i'm an environmentalist at
large right
what does that actually mean whereas
this is very directed
and is pointing people in a specific
direction to really
reframe how they think about like their
relationship to this
animal that we fear that is a you know
the the apex predator of the planet
yeah you know and it also takes an
amazing wife and daughters that
supported me because i did 36
expeditions you know that are
self-funded so i'm spending my own money
on these trips you know it's not cheap
to charter boats and
bring film crews um but you know thank
god for marvel because i was
you know shooting all these big movies
the whole thing for you
they were paying me well and i would
take that money instead of buying a
bigger home or more cars
and go do shark trips uh-huh so when you
have that first experience with that
shark and you're out your eye to eye
like you said your life changed like
what was it about that
like what did you see there that shifted
you like
like i want to know i want to understand
that better which you will
shortly that's the moment you will
shortly want to jack you into that vr
right because it's the closest thing to
being there without getting wet you'll
ever do
that was the problem i had was how do i
change people's perceptions
because that's what it is it's a
perception shift with photos it's
extremely difficult because you look at
that photo of the shark and you're like
yeah that's cool and it's beautiful but
it doesn't
really help shift the fear even you
might hear my experience
it might make me more afraid might make
you more afraid right
tv a little bit better you might have a
little bit more of a chance
changing people's perceptions watching a
box
but what i found happened and it's the
most powerful was
every year i've taken not every year but
quite a few trips i've taken out
friends a lot of them sort of influencer
types actors and athletes
to guadalupe put them on a boat actually
in different parts of the world
and brought them to see the sharks my
wife's a perfect example
so i brought her out uh with felipe and
ashlyn cousteau
and his organization we went out to
guadalupe and my wife it's an 18 hour
boat trip
cried almost the whole way i'm gonna die
i can't believe i'm doing this i'm so
irresponsible you know of course it's
gonna be the wife of white mike that
died you know yeah
and i'm just like okay babe all right
yeah yeah yeah
the second dive i think once she was not
out of the cage with her flippers on but
standing on top of the cage holding the
chain
i thought she was going to jump on the
back of the shark and swim away that's
how
fast her perception shifted and that
goes for
pretty much everyone that i'd bring out
they would go out sort of scared
what causes that shift like what is what
is transpiring that defies the
the preset in the mind well i think one
is you're not seeing what we've seen so
many times in the movies which is this
you know
shark that just wants to kill you and
you know and they're watching
me and my team out of the cage
interacting with these animals and you
can
clearly see that these great whites
really aren't you know trying to kill us
they're just incredibly smart they're
apex predators you have to have a
tremendous amount of respect because you
know they will
kill you if you're if you if you're
scared or act like prey
yeah um but i i can't tell you what's
happening
what what's happening only can give you
is my experience is that i saw this
animal in a different light
than i did you know watching the movies
and i was like oh
it's not what i was projected
yeah you had mentioned in something that
i read that that you can clearly see
a difference in personalities across
like every shark has its own
personality and you start to individuate
and notice that
yeah and and genders you know the
females versus the males you know
females are always a lot bigger um
they're more chill
they're more you know in in inquisitive
whereas the boys are
aggressive and just sort of like
swimming around fast and
just sort of like people but they all
are a little different and you
you really assess the animals when when
they come up
and you know here's here's all the other
shirts here's tiger sharks and
hammerhead like
you know tiger sharks we have to like
bait them to come in because they don't
want anything
really usually to do with this you know
in hawaii different parts they will
they'll come right up but
for the most part sharks swim the other
way when they see people you know we're
chumming the water and putting fish out
so they'll come in
so that's pretty much every other shirt
and then there's great whites right so
great whites are ambush predators so
when you swim with great whites
outside of the protection of a cage it's
not the shark that you see because
they'll be out of the cage and there'll
be a 20
15 foot whatever 17 foot where the wall
is that far
like right there and i look over as long
as we have eye contact
i'm not even thinking about i mean i am
but i'm not
my head's like this on a swivel looking
around because eventually
i'm going to usually look down and i'm
gonna see that tail going
right two and a half tons going about 20
miles an hour coming up at me like a
missile so they're coming
which i then have to turn and swim
head-on at the shark coming at me at 20
miles an hour
and the minute i start swimming towards
it it really it
looks at me and says i don't like you
you're a potential predator
and banks off wow that takes some
serious balls
so now how do you live if it's charging
you you got to charge at it
yeah so this is you know and that's the
thing there isn't like learn to swim
with great white school
you know and this isn't um this is you
know years and hundreds and
thousands of hours underwater with all
different types of other sharks
and my mentor this this man mourinho
hardenberg who's in south africa
he's the one that taught me the skills
of swimming with white sharks
out of the cage and how i learned that
was about six years ago i was out of the
cage and my flippers were down i was
like this with my camera
and i see a shark coming at me like full
speed and i grabbed my camera and i
remember in my head going like all right
rubber meets the road here we go like
i'm ready
holding my camera i'm looking down and
off this shoulder
mornay goes head-on at it holding his
red camera with the two arms and the
lights and goes straight on at it and i
watched the shark bank off and the first
thought was
that's the coolest thing i've ever seen
in my life second thought was
he just saved my life the third thought
was looks like that's what you do
and when we got up to the surface he
said okay listen when they come at you
you have to turn and swim head-on at
them
right which goes against everything and
you're you know especially after
spending five six years with them from
the cage watching those teeth and how
fat
i'm like okay the next day we were out
of the cage
and we had two of them come at us one at
him one at me i had no choice
so i did it i'm like all right here we
go if you freeze your prey
if you freeze you're done so here's what
happens so everything in the ocean
besides orcas swim away from that animal
so everything like
freaks out everything so the minute you
start swimming towards it
that's not something they're used to
seeing yeah yeah right
and the other thing is nothing touches
that animal so if you go up and even
give it a little pinch
it's just gone wow gone what about the
you always hear
you're supposed to punch him in the nose
is that a myth yeah
urban myth yeah well here's what happens
if you punch them in the nose
punch your hands that mouth no that
mouth opens up
which is really wide so one of the
things i do is before i have a
an expedition where i don't want to be
you know outside the cage with white
sharks
for the weeks leading up in my mind sort
of like baseball players visualize
i visualize that shark not turning and
what i'm gonna do and how i'm gonna
twist my body and hit my you know use my
camera to bump the side of his gills on
the sides which i've only had to do one
time and
in all of the the diving and all the
times i've spent with great white sharks
one time a shark came by and he looked
like he was going this way and at the
last minute his head went like that
my daughter my ten-year-old was in the
cage watching behind me so i was not
taking any chances and they just gave it
a little tap
right when its head moved and swam off
but never been bit i mean is that never
been
never even been really close to being
bit right
wow but you do have to be you know with
the chum in the water you have to be
really aware
of your of your surroundings because you
know a piece of fish
can float by your arm uh-huh you know
and the sharks go in for that fish and
you know catches your arm
um and you know for years people would
ask me like why do you do this are you
an adrenaline junkie was usually the
common
tag that would go with why i was doing
this and i couldn't really i couldn't
quantify i couldn't answer them why i
was doing it and i'd be like no no it's
not an adrenaline junkie thing
and then a couple years ago i don't know
four or five years ago i was under
waters with the sharks and it hit me
they made it hit me like a bolt of
lightning i'm like oh my god
this is why i do this because it was
really the only time in my life
that i felt like i was really in the
moment like in the moment
truly you know nothing else was going on
and i was like
oh my god and the hairs on my arm stood
up in my wetsuit and i was like wait
i don't want to swim with sharks to have
this this experience i want this on land
too which
led me down a path of mindfulness and
meditation and seeking that
that experience out which i it's a
practice that i try to do daily as
much as i can of being right here right
now in the moment and not up here
in the future in fear because i once i
started this project
i thought i was sort of a fearless guy
and i
really had no idea how much fear
you know ran my life but smaller things
like you know jobs and work and little
things
and then how much i would react on it
just robotically
send an email do this try to do stuff
try to make the
headset work force it you know yeah yeah
yeah instead of just being like
it's all cool and finding finding
presence
in the most treacherous environment like
we think of mindfulness
in the context of you know a calm quiet
environment but
it's fear that brings us into the moment
yeah more than anything right
i mean i gotta say for me the more chaos
and like
when i'm on my shoots and there's a
hundred people and people are what do
you want to quit
that's the most common there's like a
jedi yeah yeah i'm like who
when i'm at home and my daughter starts
doing some emotional meltdown or
whatever that's when i'm just like
right too wow that's crazy how old was
your daughter when she first
swam with sharks so i have i have three
girls i have a 16 year old and twin
13 year olds uh clara the eldest she
started doing
great white trips to me at nine and a
half i got them certified
at like nine and a half 10 and sort of
fudge their birthdays
and she's done four great white
expeditions with me
and she literally asked me last year
she's like i want to go out of the cage
and i was like i bet you do we'll we'll
talk in 10 years after you put in all
the time
all the other sharks you have to earn
that even though there's a part of me
that's so bad they want to take pretty
cool
i mean my daughters are the same age i
got two daughters 16 and 13
and i'm trying to visualize them doing
something like i'm trying to visualize
myself doing something like that like
that's
it's just that's super cool yeah i mean
i grew up my father
you know we i lived like i said earlier
i lived in saudi arabia for four years
and traveled to 60 countries before i
started high school
and um and it was one of the best so
when you're there when you live in saudi
arabia they pay you three times your
salary
free homes and all that most people just
bank a bunch of money and my dad was
like
uh like this is a once in a lifetime
we're going to travel and see the world
every three months we had a big wall map
we're like oh let's go to india let's
try sri lanka
and you've gone to like 50 countries by
the time you were in high school
yeah and i think that's you know what
planted that seed as a photographer i
travel a lot you know
now since been to close to 200 countries
but it's something i try to do with my
my family a lot and show them the world
sort of open their eyes to how good we
have it here
so there's a lot of countries that you
know people i think really take it for
granted in america like
how how blessed we are i mean we have
our fair share of issues
and uh in recent days and months and
years they're
they're growing by the day but uh we
have an amazing country here and it's
just cool to see the world and all the
different cultures
how old were you when you moved to saudi
arabia third grade
third grade what what city did you move
to my dad built was building a city
called jubail it was at the time the
world's largest construction project he
worked for a company called bechtel
a big construction you know one of the
it's like bechdel ramco floor
and he was the project manager it was
like you know building a massive
massive city so i've traveled throughout
saudi arabia um been to a bunch of
cities there
and spent some time in bahrain yeah and
what i didn't realize
that i learned when i was there was that
at one time bahrain had some of the
most amazing coral reefs anywhere and
the oil trade has just
devastated it that's where i grew up so
bahrain goes right off jubail yeah
we would take dow boat you know the dow
the wooden boats uh-huh so we'd take
dowel boats out to bahrain right
before the bridge was built or was the
bridge oh yeah before this is this is
like
late 70s yeah early 80s right before
sidon let all the oil into the persian
gulf before
this oil trade and to this day i can
see those reefs they're they were the
most untouched
gorgeous reefs i have ever seen to this
day yeah that's what i've heard
and they're gone they're gone and i
remember when
the tanker they had to didn't they have
to troll it so that it was deep enough
for the tankers i don't know exactly
what
i mean i don't know all there's probably
a bunch of different reasons why it's
gone
i just remember desert storm and the war
what affected me the most i remember cnn
showing the beach with the waves
crashing the oil waves
and i just saw those reefs wiped out and
i just was
it crushed me and i was like oh my god
those reefs are all gone that's where
you learned to scuba dive though
yeah that's where i learned to scuba
dive and you know grew up watching
cousteau and that sort of also
planted right so so dad had the
adventure
gene yeah and photography was his hobby
yeah yeah yeah so he had
all the nichromats and nikons and the
glass and gave me my first
f4 and i moved back to the united states
uh in seventh grade and started shooting
snowboarding it was just starting like
literally it was the inception of the
smort
and started shooting snowboarding when i
was like 15 and getting published
and me and my best friend at the time
who was from europe so his parents sort
of thought game has college tuition
and we started the first snowboarding
calendar uh-huh which the first year we
lost our shirt second year broke even
this are actually made when you were in
high school
yeah so you traveled where were you
where you were living in
lafayette yeah yeah right okay uh-huh so
like traveled to europe at 16 just the
two of us
shooting pro snowboarders and we drive
to colorado
so growing up overseas because we would
get to like hong kong
and i'm 12 years old and i would leave
for two hours and come back and tell my
parents like
okay the market's over here and this is
there right it's just a different time
do that now yeah that's crazy
yeah and then at some point you become
this like unbelievable triathlete
yeah yeah this part of the story it gets
lost but like this is crazy
yeah you were like a champion triathlon
yes
it was at the same time so in high
school um
you know i like seventh grade was the
worst year of my life like i mean coming
back from saudi arabia all the other
kids knew each other i knew
no one had to like socially claw my way
up
you know the ladder and sports wise i
started water polo but a year be
behind all the other guys i was as good
as that as the other guys but
wasn't getting played and it was a swim
team and this guy
started telling me he was doing
triathlons somebody can run and i was
like oh i want to try that and i went
home and told my parents like are you
serious i'm like yeah i'm dead serious
and they got me a bike and i started
riding and we lived in the berkeley
hills so it was like a lot of hills
and i would ride 50 miles a day and i
was doing water pool and swimming
and i went and did my first triathlon
which was a half ironman the wildflower
which is a yeah
it's that's a hard course freaking
gnarly i didn't know any better though
so my first race is a half ironman and i
get in 500 people start there
700 people start to swim and i can i
remember this day
this guy grabbing my shoulder to pull me
back and i'm coming out of water pool
and i look back and just kicked him in
the face
so i come out of the i come out of the
swim in fifth place overall
pros and everything my dad was like what
the f is going on like no there must be
some
problem you know some my son's in fifth
go out on the bike
come back from the bike in ninth place
uh-huh so
literally and this is out of everyone
and right and then whenever
and hot yeah go out on the run walk half
of the
the you know 13 mile run and finish 99th
overall in first in my age group and i
was hooked that was all about
i started doing them you know 15 to 20
of them every summer which was the
season
i had 1920 sponsors you know revo
sunglasses domino's pizza
side out sport and you know placed fifth
in the world at the world championships
probably would have done a lot better
but i was heartbroken wow
at olympic distance yeah yeah olympic
distance and
race against lance armstrong a branch
because that's when he started doing
triathlons before bike racing and
yeah so i would do triathlons in the
summer and do photography
and then did you when did you you moved
to san diego for a spell right
so right when i grabbed into that
community like my senior year in high
school i would get out of school at 11
because of my triathlon to go train so
uh you know when i
graduated high school the day after i
graduated like you know
june 15th i packed my car up moved to
san diego because the two meccas of
triathlon at the time were boulder
and san diego and went down there and
had a triathlon team at the time it was
i've always been a bit of an
entrepreneur and
you know like i said all the sponsors i
got myself i would go right
you know and then i was also shooting
snowboarding and rock and roll
so the other thing i did in high school
was i would write
the labels and say that i was shooting
for the local paper the contra cost of
times
the controversy to get the press pass
pass right
so i just going to rolling you name the
concert like backstage it's shoreline
backstage so i'm shooting rock and roll
and i'm shooting snowboarding and then
i'm doing my triathlons and i go to san
diego and
you know i move down to the beach and
it's just party central
and i'm looking around at these guys
that are like 21 i know i'm 17 18 and
i'm like
if i don't get out of here i'm gonna end
up a loser like these days and i'm like
what do i want to do swim bike and run
for 10
more years and then what yeah there's
not a lot of there's not a lot of
bandwidth for rock and roll when you're
living that triathlon lifestyle no well
there wasn't a lot of that level
no it was opposite it wasn't a lot of
bandwidth for triathlon because i was
planning my life i'm like what am i
going to swim bike and run for 10 years
and then what
so what do i want to do i didn't do well
in school like i wasn't like going to
stanford or anything so i'm like
photography that's what i do so i
packed up went with my buddy from high
school we did the calendar
moved to boulder colorado for a season
and
i was just heartbroken from my high
school sweetheart ripping my heart out
and doing what they do at that first
that first love you know and then um was
in boulder he got a girlfriend
was doing his thing and my best one of
my other best friends
was in la he was a musician he said come
to la come to la
i packed up moved here i was 18.
and the rest is sort of history started
shooting you know model friends and
actor friends and
and that sort of so you fell in pretty
quickly
into like the the the leo and balthazar
crowd right
balthazar they were prowling he was the
first first
non-snowboard he was the first actor i
shot so i got here scott was
really good friends with balt and davey
so i shot balthazar and david arquette
and then just friends like we all went
to the formosa all the under it was the
only part that would serve the underage
but yeah it was like leo and drew and
you know and at that time this is before
the internet and then with film you know
we just
let's go take pictures go shoot pictures
no publicist
publicist only came about when the
internet came about
um and then bans because i knew all
those labels
right from shooting the things so when i
got to la they were like oh yeah come on
in so i went and then i started shooting
spin
and i remember sven called me to shoot
some band called green day and i'm like
green day what is
green day i went up to berkeley and we
became like you know i shot all their
stuff shot their wedding shot billy
joe's wedding
i was the punk photographer when punk
sort of blew and rancid and all those
boys
that's crazy it seems like it happened
really
seamlessly and quickly yeah i mean it it
did it's like
uh you have to have the talent i think i
you know i never went to school so i
didn't learn the rules you know
um i also because i was like how am i
going to learn to shoot people right i
was shooting and snowboarding and i
found out about testing models right
because i was like
i don't ever want to assist i don't want
to watch you doing something i want to
do
to learn how to take but no i can do
this so i figured that models
need portfolios right uh to go and get
jobs so i started testing models
and i did a few for free and then i
started charging 50 year old
you know and then 100 a roll and 150 but
every one of those shoots i treated like
it was the cover of vogue or the cover
and i would be like okay i got to do six
different looks within a three block
radius and i would dress them and
and then i was shooting my actor friends
which were
you know it was like leo before titanic
and true and then but you're on the
inside you have their trust so
you could you could no i didn't go to
their parties and all that kind of stuff
i earned their trust because i would get
i would have photos that i could have
made
a lot of money with the national
enquirer but i didn't because you do
that once you might get a good payday
but you're never gonna you know
people aren't gonna trust you so i was
their friend so i would you know
shoot stuff and shoot at parties and do
stuff but i would you know i
obviously have that compass of knowing
right there's a boundary there
well there is yeah and uh yeah and then
i got agents and
started shooting you know the rest so
sort of and never
like technically trained never
apprenticed so i went to otis persons
for one semester they gave me advanced
placement because of my snowboarding
work as a junior or whatever
right and i was like what do i need a
diploma for do i need to show this to
jobs and they're like no just if you
want to be a teacher
and i'm like okay and i got paid to
learn by these models you know because i
was trying new films and
and doing different things like that and
how does the studio work start to happen
i mean didn't that begin with you
uh starting to photograph like the
superheroes outside of the
chinese theater studio work started
happening in the second
lifetime of my career
so right i'm in my 20s i'm shooting
young hollywood i'm shooting all the
rock and roll this is
early 90s nirvana and
you know young kids in hollywood with
money and success
and uh you know i
like everyone i knew at the time started
doing drugs
had a big ego that like because i was
triathlon mental like i would you know
nothing's gonna i'm never gonna have a
problem
and uh and you know formed a drug habit
that you know got me by the back what
was the uh what was the drug of choice
the problem i'm gonna move to new york
yeah the geographic that was great the
geographic
yeah you know this is the problem i'm
gonna not realizing that i'm taking the
problem
everywhere i go because michael's the
problem uh-huh
um that took years to learn that yeah so
that played itself out over a while a
long long
how many years yeah it was like you know
four or five years i was smart enough to
go like okay
i've got a drug problem here if i don't
put my camera down i'm gonna burn every
bridge
and i made a conscious decision to like
be like okay if i'm gonna be a dragon it
might be a professional triathlete
and that sort of happened same triathlon
mindset
exactly all in exactly but in the back
of my head i sort of knew
i just knew i was gonna find my way to
the other side
you know my dad was got cancer diagnosed
with cancer
so he started to you know die from
cancer that was sort of the end of my
using and when he you know passed away i
moved back to northern california
you know got arrested one last time and
uh he passed away and i got out and
and that was sort of it i you know
started going to
12-step programs yeah so that was the
the bottoming out was just
your dad passing was that the moment um
yeah that was a really
pivotal moment i think i had so much
shame and guilt that what i'd let happen
to me
that you know i i felt and like i don't
know if i would have ever gotten sober
if he hadn't passed
um because it was so bearing on me
you know i had this great career and
this life that i'd built and i'd
you know sort of flushed it all down the
toilet and
you know when i remember i got sort of
got my
started this second got sober whatever
the new part of my life in sacramento
and i remember going there i'm like
i i'm i'm staying here six months and
i'm moving back to l.a like
this is the armpit of california don't
you know who i am and i've shot leo and
drew
right and i ended up staying remember
two years because when six months came i
was like i'm not ready to go back to la
but i
i milked sacramento for all it's worth
it did you go there for treatment or
why'd you go to sacramento yeah i mean
sort of i went there
i went there under the tutelage of like
a spiritual advisor and then
got introduced to 12-step stuff so got
into all that
and then started shooting and started
seeing all the local bands
and um was and then started slowly
making trips down to la and went into
bond dutch because i was shooting all
these bands and i love their clothes
the owner saw my portfolio took me to
lunch connie
huh tawny tony no tom cassidy
who is i've seen a guy named there was a
guy in mike
and then this uh taekwondo swedish guy
named tony who
were the two owners of von dutch uh-huh
that's the thing there's a lot of
politics and then tony kicked mike out
and brought in christian adjuiler or
whatever
and the tom hardy all that good stuff
but uh the von dutch campaign came
i mean like paris hilton came in for it
but that
campaign launched and sort of put me
back on the map and the ad agency
started calling and i started doing
these like big
course campaigns with giving me the
money to come back so
i moved back to la and i remember i was
like you know
two years into this new life of mine
and uh when i was up in sacramento i was
you know dating i'm
just dating a lot of girls
but being really honest this is i'd be
like listen i'm not emotionally
available
i'll take out on dates we'll have fun
but that's all i can give you and
they're like yeah yeah cool
and then like six weeks or a couple yeah
they'd be like i can't do this anymore
i'm sorry i have feelings for you but
you told me
but i'll tell you my guy the one thing
my spiritual advisor gave
me which saved my life in a lot of
regards was he looked at me and said do
you know what you're looking for in a
wife
and i'm like yeah yeah he's like what
and i gave him the generic you know i
don't know
funny he's like no no you're going to go
home tonight you're going to write down
the 10
core principal things you want in a wife
and i was like okay
and i did and i was like you know good
relationship with dad
no kids i want to create a family not
marry into one you know has her own life
spiritual
i made all these things and i shortly
thereafter met this girl who was like a
hair stylist and a boring and did it and
i was like oh she might be the one
she had two kids on my list i'm like
you're not the one
so i moved back to la two months into
moving back
i met my wife to this you know who's my
wife now and
it was like check check check check
check and that was balthazar and his
wife rosetta are actually the oh wow
the ones who i met but uh that list
because i look back
in retrospect you cannot ever like you
just said earlier
and i was like oh my god if i hadn't
made that list and went with that
i wouldn't be sitting here talking to
you right now who's that spiritual
advisor
just uh you're being cryptic about that
but like i don't know
no one knowing you would know i've had
i've had many of those over the years
and i'll tell you those are the
those mentors that have you know there's
there's been a
dozen you know there's been a bunch that
have given me those uh and you know it's
just a matter of being open and seeking
you know it's like the the kabbalists
say the the darker
the darker you are the more opportunity
of light to reveal right so i went
really
dark which means on this new path i'm
seeking the light like
no other yeah but the darkness is the
teacher
you know i mean when i think of a
photographer
of your caliber i think of a particular
kind of lifestyle lots of women lots of
parties and you did all that
you had your moment with that and now
you have this kind of spiritual path
where you're into all this holistic
stuff
and the environmentalism and i know
you're part of like the
laird and gabby morning workout with the
wim hof breathing and the ice baths and
like all the stuff that you do
to you know be this you know be the most
authentic best version
of who you are so you can express
yourself and share your
your gift and raise your family and you
know be the man that you know you're
meant to be
yeah you know one of the one of the sort
of aha moments was
the realizing the ptsd that i had that i
didn't know
i used to talk about that i mean i you
know i've read that you've had that and
that you deal with that but what is the
origin of that
well i thought you had to go to vietnam
to have ptsd
you know i was naive like ptsd i don't
have ptsd i remember when i
first the first time i started doing you
know therapeutic work with my
you know with the counselor i was
looking at my trauma egg and i'm like
yeah it's not that bad he looked at me
and i was like michael
i work with like soldiers that come
right off afghanistan and you've seen
more [ __ ] than 95
of them like don't think for a second
that you don't have some serious
issues so you know when you have ptsd
there's big p
and small p um which i've learned a lot
from andrew huberman
and right different people about fear
and just different things but um
uh when you when you see anything that's
perceived death death or near-death
experiences it
imprints you right and i have a
different emotional reaction
than say a normal person or a person
that doesn't
so like when my wife yells it like i i
feel like i'm dying like it's
crazy this emotional reaction and if you
don't
deal with those emotions it's like a
pressure cooker stuff stuff stuff
explode right or medicate right you know
which
i think if you look at the the core
reason
why people abuse drugs they're
medicating pain
uh i'd say probably 95 of them that's
why they're taking drugs they want to
medicate they want to numb that pain
now that's one way of of going through
this life you can numb the pain right
and then you're numbing all the joy
you're numbing all the happiness you're
numbing
everything uh or you can realize those
wounds right
bandage patch let them heal look at them
as scars like i have a scar on my face
that i see every time i look in the
mirror
it's there but do i still feel that
fence ripping open
doesn't affect me but that takes work
that takes looking at those wounds
where the origins i had a lot of
childhood trauma
um you know from emotional physical
abuse
uh you know uh and then those
dark years that i was you know abusing
the drugs i saw and did a lot of things
that were just dark just yeah one of the
things you do
uh in the trauma therapy i did is a
trauma egg and you start from your
first you know your first memory of any
near death or
you know and had a big piece of paper
about half the size of this table and
started with a circle down here
circles and i literally almost filled
the egg up with music
you know near or death that i'd seen
people being killed whatever it might be
and you know i still looked at that like
i was saying and was like yeah it's not
that bad you know i didn't it's not that
bad
you didn't drive your humvee over and
you know an ied
yeah it's more like death by a thousand
cuts right like these just exactly these
incidences that would recur in your life
that
accumulate over time to create this
situation
and everyone everyone has them you yeah
life
you have these experiences in life right
that are traumatic
that are who helped you realize this
were you working with a
a therapist or yeah i think like i said
all those different you know
different spiritual people or mentors
over the years that have guided me
uh how did i find out about trauma uh
i i had a guy that i was working with in
a 12-step program
come over to my house looked at me and
he was like listen michael i don't think
i can help you
and this guy had worked with like mike
tyson and different people
and he said you have something that's
beyond which
took a lot for him because the ego says
oh i can help you know and he had the
humility to look at me and said i can't
help you i think you have something
that's beyond my
skill set i was like was it howard well
this person i'm gonna
remain nameless but he said um i want
you to call this guy
so i cold-called this guy west
and he was a guy who was 25 years sober
with a gun in his mouth
he also had you know ptsd that he didn't
know about
uh and he told me this story and he's
like michael changed my life and then he
gave me the number
of my first trauma therapist named ryan
suave
who i called ryan and he actually flew
out here and we spent four days together
out in malibu
24 hours a day doing therapeutic work
wow and it was one of the gnarliest
experiences of my life like it was
extremely tough um you know
for breath work meditating like hour and
a half long sessions a day like it was
it was hardcore and that was my first
and
you know now i do some emdr work which
is another form of trauma therapy where
you're looking at a
yeah a thing your eyes going back and
forth right
and it's it's been really cool because i
i talk about it and there's been
you know a number of people that have
come up to me and said i can't thank you
enough
i didn't know anything about it and i
actually hadn't i've addressed it and i
can't tell you my life isn't
you know and that's that's what it's all
about yeah when you can really sort of
uh pass on what was sort of so freely
given to me and so how
how is it for you now does it still show
up like is it something that you just
unconsciously have you know you know
sort of resort to these tools to manage
it or is it
quelled and kind of in your past daily
practice yeah
no man i'm stuck with michael till right
until i
till i yeah when the wife yells the
bells still go off
they they do and you know i something
i'm working on like literally today is
not reacting not taking it personal not
like realizing it's her thing it's not
mine it's it's just me i want to take an
oh my god and when i do that when i
don't react
it's freaking amazing what happens
because i don't know about your wife but
wife's like to
pull the pen and throw a grenade right
an emotional grenade
that just blows up you're like where did
that come from why are you blowing me up
and when i react it just it lasts all
night right
and when i don't it's crazy because
she'll throw the grenade or she'll say
the things and then two minutes later
she's like hey love
come over here and i'm just like wha
what you're uninstalling the buttons
yeah yeah right yeah that's because you
know and
and you know one of the things is being
a parent is this you feel this need to
protect your kids from any of those
traumatic experiences like oh i don't
want them to feel that
i i don't want them you know or at least
sometimes my wife will do it and i'm
more like
they need to go through these things the
only way to learn
is for their friends to diss them and
not invite them to that party so they
realize what it feels like
when they don't invite people to things
yeah it's a conundrum
because the most interesting people that
i know
have had those dark moments of the soul
and have
figured out for themselves how to you
know repair their lives and
they come out of it and become these
incredibly interesting amazing
productive people and then you know
you you sort of have some success and
you're able to provide for your kids in
a certain way that maybe
you weren't able to to have and by doing
that you're depriving them of certain
life experiences that can be formative
in the most positive way
yeah and then you you also i know i have
to own the things that i've passed on
that i go oh my god could she
i think in my head i had that illusion
like i'm never going to do the things my
parents did i'm going to be this great
dad and then you know in retrospect i'm
like [ __ ] i
i wasn't perfect uh you know and yeah my
my daughters let me know
yeah right but what the beautiful thing
is
i do have today you know i have this
moment to
either undo or do things differently um
and uh
you know try to fix i i have you know
pretty good amazing relationships with
my daughters i hear from
other fathers that get the hand or
whatever get the door slammed
which would suck i i don't but i've you
know that was a choice i remember
when clara was six months old a couple
studio heads different people told me
they were like they had missed they were
working all the time they missed their
kids growing up they were getting
remarried and they had their new baby
and they're like michael don't do it
and i've made a conscious decision i did
a job when claire was six months a nike
gig in greece whatever and missed the
vacation or left for part of it and i
was like eh it sort of sucked
from that moment on i've made a decision
that when i'm on vacation when like no
matter what comes up
i'm with my kids and probably pass on
some of the biggest jobs of my life
doing that
um also going to all my kids games when
i'm in town but
what i have today is a relationship with
my daughter i don't get the hand i don't
get the door slammed and
are they perfect by no means that's
beautiful um
we should uh we should jack you into
some videos yeah let's do the vr we'll
take a quick break and
report back
[Music]
that was insane cool that's my first
legitimate
vr experience period but then to have it
be your work and and just to have that
experience of
being underwater immersed surrounded by
these creatures i mean that it was
magical man yeah it's crazy
is that publicly available like what is
this it's going to be
you know a uh it's it was a year and a
half crisscrossing the planet
capturing all that you know that bait
ball the sardine run
is like the holy grail of was that
port saint john they like the armpit of
africa like porn st
john's it's um it's one of these you
know you see it on uh
like blue planet and stuff right it is
so hard to actually
get on one because it's 20 miles of of
ocean right and you know you'll see the
birds funneling down but if the
if the bait ball is moving right you
can't do it so you need the bait ball to
stay static and you need the dolphins
you need the shirt you need everything
to come together
so it's taken me three years multiple
trips
right 12 hours at sea in a zodiac all
day long looking for it right because
you'll see and then you'll
race over we have a spotter plane but
the plane's like seeing it happen
and it takes you a half an hour to get
there and
anyways and with this new technology so
the only way to shoot vr was with gopros
underwater vr
right which is gopros and i'm like i am
not making the blue planet of your
gopros so i had these uh this i met this
company virtue who had figured out how
to do stereoscopic
but this is like the first iteration of
it
120 pounds the camera was this big
with 14 black magic cameras and it was
sort of a science experiment right so
if one camera went down you lost the
whole you like right because then you
don't have the stereo
which happened on a number of dives
right so on the sardine run i was just
so many so stressed i'm like that can't
happen like i don't get a second chance
with this
yeah and i just remember we were we were
in the boat and i
saw some birds starting to drop and it
wasn't like a big amount
it wasn't like the one where you're like
that's the one and mourinho was like
i don't really i'm like well i'm going
like i don't care i'm gonna he's like
okay too i'm gonna
and we came up and came up on it which
the brewster whale hit we had a 36
minute bait ball like just the two of us
one of the best dives of my life the
brewster whale came like three feet from
me and hit the bait ball we hadn't seen
brewster whales in eight years
it was like the cherry on top and i
remember putting the camera up i'm like
please tell me please tell me that
they're all running and they were like
they're all working i'm like ah because
to this day it would i would have
it would bug me to show you that and be
like oh i wish you had seen that uh-huh
and you're a pilot too no no he was
flying that little
the microlight like i was more scared to
get in that
theme
dude it's like an iphone for your gps
i sent my producer up in it i sent like
four people up before i went up in the
thing and then of course i told the pub
like dude
don't try to impress me like you don't
need to fly two feet off the water or do
any
i don't need that it's like a go-kart
first he did it because
if you go down there there's no coast
guard in this part of africa like you're
done
like and it is the most shark infested
like he's up there and he sees great
whites on the surface
like there's sharks all over the place
there um
so we spent a year and a half doing that
and then uh
uh you know we are such i'm like a
couple years ahead of
like it's just it's in its emphasis yeah
of course
and we just didn't know what we knew we
were sitting i'm sitting on this
mountain of footage in this mountain of
iep
but you know the the outlets for it are
just sort of discovering themselves
yeah and so everybody has an oculus like
how are you supposed to
well wait i mean you can watch it on
your phone and move your phone around
but that's not the experience that you
no but that is a cool experience
so that's one of the things that um most
of the vr haven't done so we're putting
it out on mobile so everyone will be
able to watch it on your phone which is
cool because not everyone has a headset
yeah
but since covid started you can't buy
headsets they're sold out everywhere oh
really i didn't yeah and everyone's i
think just sort of sick of
netflix and all the shows that they've
seen so they're grabbing their headset
well let me
see what's on here so we have
it's done we're talking with and i don't
know if
we're in the talks with a a huge brand
to sponsor the series
um they're a little bit or the middle
it's a little bit dragging a sweet so i
might just have to release
it without them attached i really want
them attached
but it's going to come out in the next
month or two right so it's not publicly
available right
but soon so there's an entertainment
component to it it is like the
you know the blue planet of vr
experiences
underwater um but there's a therapeutic
component to this as well which is where
dr andrew hueberman enters right so when
he was on the podcast
he was sharing a little bit about it and
he was doing it in the context
of explaining how uh he was using this
modality to help people confront and
work through their fears we were talking
about david goggins and his fear of
sharks and
he was you know basically had an
experience with your work
but how did you connect with andrew and
what is the
that aspect of this whole vr thing all
about that was like the
universe transpiring is what that was um
because
i had the idea for this about four years
ago
i was sitting at lax on my way to
antigua
and i was sort of done with sharks i
spent 15 years i sort of did the book i
did some tv shows i just
was like i don't know what else i can do
really and it's so hard to change
people's perceptions unless i can bring
in i can't bring everyone you know and
i'll still do a trip
a year or whatever but i'm not going to
do what i've been doing
and i'm going to start my horse project
which i my next book with tashan is a
horse book
um and i'm sitting at lax and i'm like
vr
that's the future and i'd never put a
heads on never tried it i just was in my
head going that's the future where do
people want to explore
space nasa owns that underwater i own
that
and i started in my head i'm like it's a
camera that has
it's a ball of cameras it's a camera's
pointing everywhere
so if i put that camera on a stick and
it's pointing everywhere i'm
taking you with me hold on i can take
you on all the dives with me
and i picked up the phone before we
boarded and i called my media company i
said i want to make the blue planet vr
but i want to do it for natgeo or
discovery i want to own it will you call
the top five production companies and
see if they're interested
i'm going into you i'll call you in
three weeks when i'm back i get back
i i land literally in like miami and my
phone's like
and he's like they all want to meet you
i'm like oh great that means it's a good
idea
so i get home on a wednesday start
making those calls
two days later saturday i get a phone
call out of blue from andrew huberman
who knew ryan suave my trauma
you know guy and he said hey i'm
interested in your shark work and i'm
like yeah okay
he's like this is xander human had a
neuroscience stanford but
he's like were you scared of sharks and
i said yeah i was petrified of them
and he's like okay and now you swim with
great whites with no metal suit no
protection just your camera and i'm like
yeah you see
what you've done in the neurology is
like the free climbing of neurology and
you've rewired your brain
and i want to bring you up here so we
can start working with you and studying
with you
because i want to use vr technology to
help people overcome ptsd and anxiety
and he didn't know about andrew
interesting vr
i'm starting a vr project right now
and i have ptsd and he's like no way
i'm like yeah we ended up talking for
like two hours that night you guys are
kind of cut from the same class totally
but i didn't know i'm thinking a
scientist with the white lab coat and
the
and i ended up flying up to stanford and
we met and like
of course when i met him i'm like work
too you know he's like not your typical
scientist
like he tend to rock and roll and you
know all the things so i do remember
the first thing he did say to me because
i'm going to tell your listeners
something some of them might
enjoy hearing this he's like do you
smoke and i'm like no but i chew
nicorette
because when my daughter was born i
stopped smoking i started trying to
knicker it and
at that time my daughters and my wife
and everyone was on me to quit
and i really didn't want to but i you
know i was like whatever and
i'm like nobody can neck right he's like
oh that's actually
good for you sort of well he didn't say
that he said we actually that's the
first thing we give alzheimer's and
parkinson's patients is nicorette to
chew
it's the perfect delivery because
nicotine is a stimulant and it helps
their memory and it helps their focus
and it's it doesn't work with smoking or
chewing tobacco just nicker it i'm like
yes no wonder that's why i love it well
then i'm not stopping
that i don't want parkinson's
and then i i was with a big actor buddy
of mine whose doctor told him the exact
same thing because he'd choose it so i'm
like yes i'm not joined
anyways um we started you know we
he built his vr lab at the time you know
he had nothing so
you know he started building lab i
brought five of his scientists out to
guadalupe because i'm like
so the first thing i was like i need to
make a proof of concept right to raise
money
i needed to raise money right to make a
vr the blueprint of your i need money
and i didn't know i needed cameras at
the time but i got the gopros
went out to guadalupe with him and four
of his scientists
and that year i don't know if you ever
saw the great white that got caught in
the cage
no it went viral it was on every news
cnn
so a great white gut they pulled the
bait and there's little windows for
cameras in the cages
and this little juvenile great white you
know its tail went and it squeezed
through
and it's thrashing around inside the
cage someone's filming all this
and they're watching and like 45 seconds
30 seconds later they pull up the top
and the shark you know
jumps out and swims out and then a
person pops up
and there was someone in the cage the
whole time
and there's a whole politics with that
anyways that went viral so there's a lot
of pressure
at that time on all the boats and the
mexican government everyone was pissed
and like you guys look like you're
responsible so here i am asking to go
out of the cage which is illegal and you
know whatever with a big vr
ball camera and they said we're going to
let you do it
because you you're doing it for ptsd
like we're going to turn
turn we're going to turn the way the
other and let you do so i made it and my
takeaway coming back was all right i
need to raise millions of dollars
and i need to build a whole new camera
system that doesn't exist because i'm
not using gopros and i need to do both
of those things in like
three months because animals are
migratory so if i don't get it done in
three months i have to wait a whole
other year
and i went up to facebook and i started
because blue planet took
six years and 60 million dollars
somewhere in that five years and 50
million whatever a lot
to get done and i was like i'm going to
do this in a year and i need you know
not that much money but you know
whatever 10 of that
a lot and no one was putting money into
vr
especially this type of vr like you know
facebook's like yeah it's really cool
because when i cut it when i put it
together i was like holy sh
this is like this is amazing
um and i want it to be stereoscopic
anyways long story short and this is
sort of
how i know the universe transpired with
the whole thing so i met andrew
doing that which we got a permission to
exit the cage because of the scientific
work within with mercy ahoya so we
were elite allowed legally to leave the
cage and film when we were down there
my chiropractor of all people has this
book and his office signed and he does
you know he does
all the clippers and you know right
who's who in hollywood or whatever right
rihanna's walking out bieber's
you know he's that guy and he calls me
he's like hey one of my clients wants to
meet you he saw your book and i'm like
yeah dude anything for you sure
uh tomorrow peninsula hotel i'm like
great hang up i call them back like and
i'm like
who am i meeting you could be anyone who
no but i call them back i'm like
who am i meeting because this could be
oh it's a great guy's diaries like a
billionaire and he loves the ocean i'm
like
okay great so i go down the next morning
i bring the vr with the little
two-minute sizzle thing
show it to him and he's like oh you know
he takes it off and he's like holy [ __ ]
like wow that is amazing
i'm like i'm looking for an investor
he's like you have a business plan i'm
like yeah he's like oh send it to me you
know maybe i'll do it dude
i'm like great send it to him radio
science for three weeks
so i remember laying down like three
weeks later in bed i'm like that guy's
you know flaking
all right i'm gonna put out the great
white thing and i'll try to sell that
raise the money to do the rest
the next morning i get a text from him
he's like so sorry i was in the cayman
islands
i want to invest can you be in texas
tomorrow and i'm like yeah yeah i'll be
in texas tomorrow
so i went out and i sat across and i
said listen we don't have the time to
like
do a month-long negotiation i need the
money i need like tomorrow or we're
gonna miss
and we hammered out a deal and he was
like the dream investor sort of blank
check
wow with his only his goal was to go on
some cool dives with me like
that was all he wanted out of the deal
he didn't expect like anything special
to be made or whatever he just wanted to
go on some cool dives
which he got to go on some times of his
life i gotta say
and we cut uh that film that you saw who
brought becca
film festival and it blew up mccann film
festival called and i brought it there
um and then you know we decided to just
put it out ourselves and instead of
making like four films of course
the the addict as you say and me i'm
like
i'm going to do all of them at once and
editing nine different films and then
it's taken me a good year and a half and
i have
amazing academy award-winning composers
and
rock paper scissors like one of the best
editing right just amazing
you know people around me and it's been
a it's been a really amazing experience
so the full series is what like nine
hours long no no no it's it's uh
it's almost two hours so there's nine
films that range between
five minutes and 10 minutes and i had
like eli
roth uh do the video on one of them
because i was like i don't want to hear
my voice on
every single one and then like laird and
his daughters and my daughters came on a
trip so
the great white trip sort of from the
eyes of the kids and their dads
you know me and laird and laird talking
so and there's orcas like sort of rays
and manatees and ocean crocodile
saltwater crocodiles
it's it's cool that's super cool so
coming to
your oculus soon yes coming to your
oculus coming to every
your oculus or your htc coming to any
headset and then coming to your mobile
phones and
pricing it so that in a way that
everyone will but
no one has an excuse because most of you
are out there that's priced
in my opinion is too much people aren't
into pain but if it's
a couple bucks for the whole series what
about the um
work that you're doing with andrew
specifically though like taking this
footage and
using it in a way that's helping people
overcome their fears or dealing with
their ptsd well i know he's
in the process they're you know doing
some writing some papers so i
don't know what i'm really allowed to
talk about i know they've had some
amazing successes up there with the
reduction in stress
doing breath work protocol different
things to help people relieve their
stress
and what he created was like a vr space
where they go in
because how do you face a near-death
experience
you know i mean like a realistic one
like if you go to the front lines of
afghanistan and bring a vr camera
why people are shooting at you going out
of a cage with a shark is
sort of a near-death experience in a way
that i can sort of film it and control
it
so they can see it do being used in
various ways like you could go cave
diving or you could just all these
the classical these kind of things that
that create fear in people
yeah and they're monitoring people
imagery sweat glands like everything
going on
so when you're wired up and you're in
the lab in the video
yeah you see you and andrew like what
are they monitoring and like what you'd
he did tell me one thing so one of the
first tests they did is where
you put on the headset and you basically
are on a high wire in between buildings
or you're a plank
so to speak and they say that's
terrifying take four steps out which i
do
turn to your right and and then they're
like step you know take a step forward
and i'm like in my mind i'm like i'm in
my head said i'm like okay well this is
you know this is what it's like to kill
yourself so i'm going to enjoy it
and i jump off and then i hear them
outside of the headphones like mumbling
and
reboot they're like okay we're going to
have you do it again
so i did it again and this time i'm like
well i'm going to look down this time to
see what it's
like with the ground coming like if
you're going to jump off a building to
like watch it come up at you which i did
so after that he said i can't tell you
about all your other results but
i will tell you this you are the first
and only person that's ever done
that experience that sort of didn't
like tiptoe out like you just jumped off
no one does that and he said we thought
you messed up so we had you do it again
and you did it again both times and he
just was like
that means what that you've worked
through your fear response and uh
he wouldn't tell me what that means but
it was interesting i was when you
watched like the documentary free solo
with alex honnell yeah he was doing the
mri and his
you know the front part of his brain
isn't lighting up yeah
so one of the things so me and andrew
talk to him about that i had him on the
podcast and we talked all about that
yeah i actually just saw jimmy chen like
he's a really good friend of mine
well he's been on the show yeah the best
i love jimmy
um you know uh me and alex i mean me and
um
andrew have a trip we're planning on
going in two months
you know we think that they'll allow us
because of the scientific work out to
guadalupe because it's closed because
covet everything's closed but one of the
things you know
we really want to study is when we're
out of the cage so like if we take you
out of the cage it's never done it
what's going on
your reaction compared to what's going
on
in my reaction what's lighting up like
eventually we'd love to be able to look
at our brains
wow out of the cage and see you know
what's
lighting up and what's not lighting up
uh so stuff like that
um uh and um you know one of the things
i
have been doing is like human guinea pig
testing colors like do shark see colors
so i had patagonia
which is a company that i work with make
me different colored wetsuits
to see the reactions of the sharks which
sure enough
from the small study that i've done they
definitely are attracted to yellow
yeah not any other color but the yellow
they were just like choo-choo coming at
me really
and then i found out mick fanning when
he got attacked and jay bae his the
bottom of his board was yellow so i'm
like ah
so that's good knowledge to have because
you can tell divers and you can tell
you know people that are in shark
populated water
sell them avoid yellow not that i've
seen but there's a you know there's
those companies that make
supposed shark repellent wetsuits that
are striped and what have you
uh i didn't have so that's i'd like to
get my hands on one of those to sort of
show that it works or doesn't work my
guess is
at least with great whites it's not
going to work that's interesting about
yellow
yeah i've had some funny i had a company
call me up and say
they were making stickers for the bottom
of surfboards this is
this is true story uh and they were like
will you put on so it's like two
eyeballs and like a scary mouth
to make your surfboard look like a
monster and this guy
really thought that it would he
literally was dead serious i want you to
go out in guadalupe and paddle on a
surfboard to show that this will
scare away and i'm like have you ever
seen a great white and he's like no i'm
like
yeah i didn't think so why don't you go
out on a surfboard and paddle your
little stickers on the board because
i am not going to do that and i can't
even believe that you're asking me to
like you're insane
so people uh there's some interesting
ones out there
it always struck me as odd that that
most wetsuits are black though because
uh then you just look like a seal look
like a seal right
yeah well you gotta think when when you
and i'm sure you've seen those on shark
week so whatever when they show a seal
and a surfer up at the surface
it wouldn't matter what color you went
to because you're silhouetted against
the light so you're just
you're always going to look black you're
looking like a seal
but sharks are so smart we've put
cameras in decoys so in south africa we
we tow fake seals behind the boat to get
them to breach on them to take photos of
them and see
etc right so we've put cameras and
literally nine times out of ten the
shark realizes it's fake before and it
turns off
um you know i was actually able and
you'll see in the book to capture the
first great white breaching at night
time
which no one the scientist because i was
like does it breach at night because i
had my lights
the strobe doesn't work during the day
right so you want to go back at night so
i went back at night and we had one and
it
and it hit and i took the photo too
quick i got too excited because
all you got to see is the white water
exploding and it's night and you're in
the back of the boat
i'm like [ __ ] because i got the head not
the body out
and i put the camera back and they never
never breached twice on a on a on a
decoy
ever and i for whatever reason put my
camera back in like 10 seconds later the
short
hit it again and i waited a tenth of a
second and then hit it and got the first
ever
which ran on the new york times magazine
it was it was really cool
to be able to show scientists a behavior
that had never been captured before
that's the gunshot yeah it was a proud
so in the book there's you have both
right there's one where
that you just see the head kind of
coming out and then you have the full
breach right so
that was the first one yeah right yeah
that's the same shark
yeah it was a little one but it was it
was really cool
to see all lit up like that it's crazy
yeah it's neat having those you know i
mean
it's it's when i would go down to
guadalupe
you know six assistants holding lights
in different places
and historically you can't talk right
but i did get an
ots system so i could talk and my
assistants because
you know otherwise they're looking at
coordinating all of this
we try to get hand signals i'm like and
all they're seeing is bubbles and me
doing this
you know it's frustrating i never yell
at my guys like when i'm shooting in the
studio or whatever there's
i'm not that guy a lot of photographers
are i guess
but i don't but i've never yelled at
them more than underwater of course
none of them heard it it's just me going
bubbles but
yeah but you're also in a situation
where all you can do is set the stage
you can't control what transpires on
that stage you can't tell them
hey you gotta go back i mean when we'd
come up and be like hey
next time would you try to do this and
you know but these guys are like they're
holding lights and they're seeing short
they're not like
at the end of the day they're like oh my
god that shark's cool and the light's
going down
um it's got to be wild though like you
just mentioned
the photograph of the shark running in
the new york times like when you see
your work
out in the wild like your works
everywhere we didn't even talk about
all the studio work that you do i mean
you've photographed
the posters for every blockbuster
essentially
at least all the marvel stuff like
everywhere you turn your work is like
omnipresent in the world
yeah yeah i've done a lot of um
a lot of you know out campaign a lot of
images people have seen that
you know i'm people of joker call me
like the most famous photographer you've
never heard of
yeah you're kind of aw shucks about the
whole thing but yeah
you know it's pretty [ __ ] awesome i
learned i learned a while i was guilty
of having that like i want to shoot the
cover of vanity fair i want to do this
and i did realize like none of that
stuff fulfills you like the minute you
get
that you're like okay what's next well i
want to do this like it's never going to
be enough
and i remember it was sort of around the
same time that like herbert's helmet
newton
and i think it was irving three master
photographers died within a year
and i watched the photography world not
miss a beat
and i remember just going like it really
doesn't matter what pictures like
if i was to die today like there's
another guy yeah it's just
selling her miss on yeah they're gonna
like it's it's
gonna go and then when my time comes i'm
not gonna say oh bring me
bring me that photo of that marvel
avengers thing no
i'm gonna want my family and the people
i love around me right
so what are my priorities and i just
sort of stopped i mean
i do have the once like when kobe passed
the cover of time magazine i thought
that was cool just because
he was he was such an amazing guy he was
a huge shark fan and
you know he's an icon and that was an
honor it was more of an honor
i was humbled at that yeah um you know
yeah we should just say for people that
are watching or listening who don't know
you're the person who photographed that
iconic image of kobe that ended up on
time magazine
and that has become the definitive most
iconic
photograph of kobe that in his passing
has kind of resurfaced as
you know the emblem of who this
individual was
yeah yeah it was uh yeah it was
you know that's those are the bitter
sweet covers yeah but
like there's a part of me that's like
really like this is how i'm getting time
magazine
because kobe like i don't want kobe to
pass to get the cover of time
at the same time i know kobe would want
the coolest shot of him on the cover of
time mag
you know what i mean um so you know it
was
it was an honor i thought that photo
that was the last ad campaign he did for
nike before he retired as a laker
so it was like his last shoot but
what uh people might not know is that
kobe was a huge
shark freak like he had a photo a print
in his locker to fire him up
and he we talked because i shot him
quite a few times
and you hear about the mamba but you
don't hear about the sharks i know
that's why
i'm i'm giving you a little a little
back story so he
he really wanted to go see great whites
right and he was like well can you
can i take a helicopter out there
because it's an 18-hour boat trip to
guadalupe
and i've tried over the years because i
have some sort of high-profile friends
who don't have
the time to go do it so can i get a you
know a jet out can i take a plane
so i've looked into all those and
there's like a seaplane where i
but he's like can i do a helicopter i'm
like no but then i stopped and i'm like
well
if there's any way to figure out a
helicopter out there it's you so i'm not
gonna say no but i don't think he can
maybe nine months later he came in i
think it was for turkish air i don't
know what it was but he comes up
literally
there's you know 80 people on the set
and people are like hey and he
he i could see him lasering on me and he
comes right out he's like hey
i did it i did it and i was like you
took you got the helicopter he's like no
no i went on the short trip i'm like oh
how did you get there he's like i had to
take the boat i'm like ah
i knew it but uh he did it without you
though yeah i know he did it
yeah he did do it without me wow
so you spent quite a bit of time with
him
yeah i mean i didn't spend i mean i just
shot him quite a few times over the
years he was one of my
uh when i first shot him i was doing a
lot of work with espn magazine
and the editor i gave her my like i
really want to shoot kobe because i had
laker season seats for
six years me and my daughters would go
to all the the games when they won their
championships and
um he was on my list it was him muhammad
ali
that was like two others and i remember
when she called she's like okay i'm
getting here you're
i was like no way and i did my you know
first shoot with them then i you know
ended up shooting for the other stuff
but
yeah i just you know it's there's a lot
i i feel like um
most of the higher profile celebrities
actors and a lot of music they
they have a fascination with sharks
people love
guys especially but there's some females
out there too alpha
mentality what is that yeah i think it's
that and
and they're the apex predator over the
oceans you know i mean they're you know
they're great white shirts like you know
everyone watches shark week i feel like
and
you know people love sharks love to hate
them love
you know it's that fear fascination
thing when you
look at that image of of kobe and it you
know given that it's
it's become so iconic like to you what
is the
what makes the difference between like a
good photograph
and a timeless photograph like that
well i know that every time i'm
shooting i'm trying i'm aiming for
iconic you know i'm aiming for thomas
i'm aiming
to show something or someone in a way
that they haven't that you haven't seen
before
that's my goal so whenever i'm shooting
people i'm trying to pull out of them
also they're real like take the mask off
so to speak and
give me that emotion show me who you
really are um
and i do that in a way that i usually
shoot very quickly
and i direct um so that the person
because in my experience no one really
likes getting their photo taken it's a
very vulnerable
uh their insecurities come out right
like oh my god my double chin oh i'm
balding like
when you show anyone 90 photos of
themselves they're not looking at the
one and being like god i look amazing
look at that shot look how good i look
they're going right to the one that
they're like oh my god
i'm so fat i need to you know what i
mean like well i don't know if you know
what i mean but that's what happens when
you show people
and if 99 of them are good and one's
like
whatever they're going to the one so i
try to you know i i go for that and you
know with the kobe obviously it was
circumstances and you know the position
and the shots and what have you but um
you know it's
it's something i don't look at
photography i don't go down to magazine
racks i don't look online
i don't want to be entertaining by
anyone else right
i really shoot in the moment and go for
what
what i'm going for you know so but it is
hollywood right so it's that
it's that that trope of like that's why
they're hiring you because they want
your unique perspective your
specific look but then there's a whole
committee of people
that like i i would imagine if you're
shooting like a marvel campaign
they want it to be a very specific way
right so there's got to be some kind of
tension creative tension there no not
well yes and no like uh you know marvel
i i started with iron man one from the
beginning
um and you created the look then i
didn't create the look but i helped
create the look i played a part in it
and i think they respect that
my my experience and my talent
so it's a collaboration it's me it's the
actors
it's the studio it's the marketing
people you know i'm one
part of the machine it's definitely by
no means me
but i do play a part um and um
they they look for for my input and
that's why i think they come to me
because
i've never a pr you can approach those
like oh it's just another job and go in
and do the routine like put the white
zingers up shoot things do the lights
the hero shot but i am and i think my
clients see that always trying to raise
the bar
so like i remember on one of the
avengers you know i brought in bands uh
because we were gonna do a big battle
scene
so instead of having them sort of pose
like fight things
i had those elastic bands so that they
could really get into
you know their things and relaxing their
veins and their neck because i want it
to feel real i want it to be a real
moment
you know and when i'm shooting uh actors
or a person and i want to laugh
you can't be like hey laugh because then
they're like and you
it's there's nothing resonate so i will
say something to make
myself look like an idiot or something
to get them to laugh or if someone says
something and they laugh my finger is
always on the trigger
so i'm like and i get that reel
and and when you look at the photo it
resonates through
you know yeah so in shooting these
all the the the quote-unquote like
superheroes like what is your what do
you think is your
strength or your superpower because like
you said there's
tons of talented photographers out there
but there's a reason
why you're the guy who gets selected to
shoot all these massive campaigns like
what is it
and it's it's got to be more than like
well i i have a unique
you know angle on it or i try to make it
real like what is it about you that
you're the guy i think it's a
combination of things
i think it's a combination of my my
abilities to light
uh i i've mastered lighting you know
that's what photography is is lighting
how you light and and i can light things
in a variety of ways
my relationship with talent and how i
can disarm people
and get actors to maybe do things that
they
don't want or like give us the extra
time that are willing to do that
because i respect them i respect their
time and i respect their opinions
what they're comfortable and not
comfortable doing i never force someone
to do something they don't want or try
to trick them or
so there's that respect level there's
the creativity that i bring
to uh to my jobs uh and like i've said
i'm always i'm i guess i have a bit of
people pleasing to me and i'm always
trying to raise the bar and i'm trying
to make my clients happy
um and at the end of the day when it
comes to the big movies
these things are 300 million dollar
investment
they know that i'm going to deliver no
matter what happens
and when you've got actors and i'm i
can't tell you how many films
like i remember on a few of the
wolverines or whatever you know we had
hugh for eight minutes
because they're they're making a movie
uh-huh right and we're like the
illegitimate step child that like you
know all right here you can have them
for 10 minutes
even though it's the biggest it's what
gets but it's forward-facing aspect
of the whole movie man people go to
movies because of the trailer on tv and
because of those billboards and you look
up and you go oh that looks dope and
you're going to go or that looks so bad
and you're probably not going to see it
an incredibly important part of it
but for some reason does not get the
priority that it
in my opinion should and so
i no matter what happens we'll get those
shots and
you know i've had hugh for eight minutes
and done three different lighting setups
and gotten them everything from the
intense portraits to the fighting to the
this and that
and i think they know that and they're
not going to tr you know it's like do
you want to try this new guy
right yeah you know and have download
you have robert be like uh yeah you know
so right
and then you know i've had that i
remember i remember robert
on iron man 2. uh
the first iron man the suit was like up
to he had like half of his body or
whatever right that's
things are not comfortable the acting
yeah the real suits and what have you
and on iron man 2 um we're at this we're
at the studio and
whatever he's not going to care if i
talk about this studio people are
probably
i don't know he was like they were like
um will you
uh he won't put the suit on he won't put
the the head piece on the shoulder piece
and he won't do it we've all asked him
will you ask him and i'm like
are you kidding you're you want me to go
ask him
he said no uh-huh please because he
likes you he'll do it
like oh my god so i go over and i'm like
robert listen
i know i can photoshop your face in but
it it's not the same
it's not the same organic because anyway
he's like he literally looked there was
like six of them and he's like
i'll bleed them and he went like that
he's like listen for you i'll do it 10
minutes all right great
start this up i'm like no no no 10
minutes of shooting like i need 10
minutes
he's like yeah that's fair that's fair
right so he sat down
he fixed and he's all right start the
stop launch they started it
i shot 580 frames in 10 minutes
and i got it all like the handout did it
all
and that was it iron man 3 had a black
with green dot like he's never put the
suit on again and
i would never ask him again uh-huh oh
right but you had that trust you'd
engendered enough goodwill with a guy
like that
yeah no i i have that and and i think i
i have that with uh with with the the
actress you know listen i've been
shooting for 35 years in this town
i've pretty much shot them all like
they've either i've either shot them or
you know i think they're gonna know
coming in my my pedigree
and respect that i know what i'm doing
right um but at the end of the day they
want to get in and out
and actors are used to being directed i
think everyone wants direction like tell
me what to do
and i tell them you know what i mean and
it's you know it's an interesting
position when you're a photographer and
you have some of the most powerful
people on the planet
and you're like you know barack obama
like look here like i know you're right
look
you're telling people what to do it's a
little exhilarating and they're doing
what you tell yeah it doesn't matter
you get to be in charge of them i am and
when you walk in
i am in charge and it starts with me
from the from the stylist the hair
everyone
and if there's any indecision if there's
any fear
any of that it's like a virus right so
no matter what's happening i can be in a
studio
and 12 of my 13 lights blow up and i'll
still be fine i'll be like cool as a
cucumber
okay take that one light bring it over
here get that bounce board and do
it it'll never show fear because it's
just like what's the solution feel
secure and safe that you're in control
and you know what you're doing
yeah and the motto in my motto and i
think it's with life is
what's the solution not what's the
problem what's the solution
what are we going to do what do we need
to do you know and i think
approach that with life too you know
what is
what is your relationship with
creativity like how do you think about
that as an energy
we talked about earlier that moment you
know like when you're meditating when
you quiet everything down
and that channel because i don't think
great ideas come from me
i think they're given to me from the
universe i think they come down
and i truly do believe if you have a
good idea
like 10 people are getting that at the
same time and it's who's first to
implement yeah i don't feel like i'm
some terminally unique that i'm the only
one getting ideas but
really did you read uh elizabeth
gilbert's book big magic
it's all about that it's all about the
the idea that that like great ideas are
out there and it's about honing your
antenna and there's a reason why
um people kind of have those ideas at
the same time and it's about who's the
right receiver for that
yeah i started reading buddha and the
badass
which is uh really implementing the the
same type of thing
uh bending reality and manifesting
he gave me words to things i've been
doing my whole life but i never had a
word for it
and there's like a little step process
in there about getting the right team
around you
because when you have an idea which i
believe is really true
and the universe will give you all the
things
really quickly to get it done if you
believe and you're in the right place
and like a bus you need the right people
in the right seats to get things done
especially bigger projects right uh
which i know i've shared with you a
couple i'm working on a
i'm working i'm a founder and a company
we have a new material that looks acts
feels like plastic but dissolves in
water and in five to ten minutes it's a
game changer and he showed me some stuff
about this
it's a great example of you know
starting a company starting a project
and having the right people around
and you know the right people coming in
to then
implement it and then only in the future
we'll
be able to look back and see the dots
that connected you know
to to to get us to where we're going but
you have to be open
for those uh uh-huh anyways buddha and
the badass is a great book
yeah and you're going to solve the
plastic problem i'm going to
yeah i'm going to help because i'll tell
you diving the amount i do
the plowing the amount of plastics that
are in our ocean
is just mind-boggling and the micro
plastics
you go look at the beach and you see all
those little pieces of plastic
well that the fish are eating and then
we're eating the fish
which means plastic is going into us
and it's uh nine million tons
enter our ocean every year it's a
nightmare so to have a
solution for single-use plastic that's
gonna about to come out and i think
it'll be
uh it'll be revolutionary and it'll be
it's exciting to be part of it
when you hear a hundred million sharks
are killed every year
what where what is what is going on why
are they being i mean you hear about
shark fin and all of that but is it at
that scale
100 million sharks yeah for that yeah uh
it's it's it's been uh gut-wrenching to
look at
um there's 2500 i think fishing vessels
off ecuador right now
sorry to say but they're all from china
uh you can see them on satellites
because of covid right there's no
they're not out people aren't out
protecting
and literally i remember when i was in
the galapagos a year and a half ago they
had captured an
illegal fishing vessel that had 10 000
ten thousand ton just some obscene
amount number of
dead sharks they had a dead pregnant
whale shark in there
and they just you know they go and they
just drop that they just kill everything
in its path
uh and then there's long lining where
they're killing everything to get a
certain fish but like they're killing
dolphin and turtles which
what i don't understand is if you went
to any country and you put
a line of hooks out in a forest and you
killed all the bears and squirrels and
raccoons
and you killed animals at that level
people would be up in arms
up in arms but we do it in the ocean and
uh when you kill the top predator of a
very fragile the top of the very fragile
ecosystem which the sharks are they keep
the oceans healthy
it's like a domino effect that's going
to happen yeah and then you look at the
ecosystem unstable
seven of eight people on our planet live
off the ocean you know that's where they
get their substance and when you start
having no fish they're gonna go to
you know africa these they're gonna they
keep having to go farther and farther to
try to find a fish like they may catch
one shark in a month
where they used to catch one every day
yeah i mean isn't that part of why
the somali pirate thing started to
happen because
the fishing dried up right well these
countries
certain countries will go in and say
we'll build you a power plant we want
all the fishing rights right like you
give them a flower plant and then they
just pillage the whole ocean
until there's nothing left they throw
dynamite out onto the reefs to just blow
up and kill
all the fish it's it's insane the way we
treat
our planet um you know i do believe
though that mother i've just seen
mother nature i've seen our the power
that you know and i think we see it now
more and more with the fires and
everything like
if we don't solve it mother nature will
for us you know and swat us off her back
like
flees off a dog you know on that tip um
you're like really good friends with
joaquin phoenix right who's really
you know at the forefront of getting the
animal welfare
message out to the mainstream yeah
so where did that kind of come together
how did that you go way back with him
right
we do he is he is a really good friend i
will say he
uh i'm gonna keep it really brief
because i respect his privacy which is
why we're really good friends
um he he's been an amazing inspiration
to me the way he leads his life
the roles he takes with his work
with his creative work the roles he
takes with our planet
and how he lives his life he lives by
example and he's been an
amazing example to me and an amazing
friend
uh one of or just an amazing i keep
saying the word amazing but just a
really big heart
i love them and i'll leave it at that
yeah have you been to any of the cow
vigils
i have yeah you should shoot those
i did i wanted to make a vr do you know
sean monson
i do yeah he just actually texted me on
the way here
um i went down with him and a couple
people but i was thinking about making a
vr of it
you know like so you can see i mean it's
it's gut-wrenching right
seeing those poor cows and people
spraying the water and
yeah it's uh in fact i just got a text
from the guy who did game changers you
see that
james yeah yeah it's it's uh it's cool
to see
movies like that take an impact you know
i think that's what i made this series
for isn't our generation
like i've written off our generation
it's this next one you know these kids
they're the ones we've got too and i am
excited i don't know if it's just an la
thing
i live in la so i see young people in la
i don't know if this is how they are in
kentucky or
ohio but like a lot of them are vegan
like they're really pissed off at the
climate
you know that they're inheriting and
they're sort of like activists i feel
like they
they're they're pissed i mean you have
that it's like one or the other they're
either really lazy and don't want to do
[ __ ] and expect you know they want to be
a millionaire by the time they're 21 but
not really do anything to get the
millionaires
and then at the flip side you see these
activists these young you know it's like
greta like you see these kids
and they're like hey f f you man you're
really giving us a planet that's this
messed
which boggles my mind and you know i go
like how does the owner of show or
mobile
they have to have kids and grandkids
like don't you
care about our planet like i think
there's such a
level of of denial and a distribution of
responsibility and those massive
organizations that allows them to
you know lay their head on the pillow at
night and feel like they're not as
culpable as they really
are and i think the accumulation of that
has created this next generation who are
so
hyped to like what's going on and so
committed to change and so
open to these new ideas and that really
gives me hope i mean our generation
you know it's like trying to get people
to change their minds especially right
now about anything
good luck with that right but yeah it's
it's like the sharks you know people are
scared to share some jaws and stuff you
know i think
uh our movies and tv and we have
promoted this like money makes you happy
like you have to have a lot of money and
success and
and it's when you look at the facts that
like you have a baseline of 50
happiness and no happiness comes from
any type of financial 40 of happiness
comes from giving
so when you give is where you get your
joy and happiness from it's not making a
bunch of money
and you get the same effect of if you
get if i handed you 25 000
what you would feel right 25 000 cash
and if you also do this and you smile
the same feeling
like you get the same yeah neuro yeah
yeah from
from straight straight from huberman's
mouth straight from scientific not humor
man but i did hear
from scientific so it's like you know uh
giving like it's like you know just
and that's been that's been the law i
have my peers ask me how do you work so
many you work more than anyone i know
and i look at them every single person
that asks me and i say the same thing
because i give i'm a u.n global advocate
i go to africa and all over the
and document refugees and then i try to
help with the sharks like
i constantly and it's a universal law
it's a law
if you give it comes back like it does
and it comes back
tenfold yeah uh people just but they're
afraid you know so i don't
need the next you know right yeah i mean
i've experienced that in my life a
thousand times over and i've seen it
happen in so many other people's lives
and it's something that
you know we hear and we can
intellectually kind of understand but on
some level we feel like it doesn't
really apply to us like i can imagine
somebody listening to this
saying that's all great because you're
so successful but you know if i got that
billboard or if i got that job then you
know it would be different from me
and it's just not the case there is a
spiritual law yeah
that takes place and actually you can
use it selfishly like if you're
desiring to advance your life in a
certain way
just start giving more even if it's not
coming from a place of
heart purity right it's coming from a
place of like personal a personal desire
to advance your life it doesn't matter
yeah it still will work it still totally
works you know i don't know why
neither do i but and i love and you know
it's sort of like you know greg owens
science show uh the most giving people
i've ever met
that's why i'm bringing them up as an
example when the kobe image you know i
knew people wanted
they're going to want that image a print
of that image and as an artist you know
i make
gallery i make editions okay i sell
shark prints right
so the first thing i did was i made that
kobe print available
like eight by ten a sort of smaller size
for a very affordable like
thirty forty dollars i called greg well
he had called me and we both talked
and i was like i want to give a hundred
percent of it away
and he's like great cool like yes
because most business well what about 50
you know yeah people are like i want to
give it all
away which we did and we gave to this
amazing organization called genesis
and she actually just called and was
like i cannot tell you how much that
money like chain you know
just open up a ton of doors but you know
look at his medicine you know i just
love meeting people that they
use that in their life and you get to
see
the fruits of the largest of their own
life yeah uh
you know expands you know to a degree
that's exponential
in proportion to the amount of giving
yeah and you see it time and time again
and i think that print
you could buy it on the sideshow website
right now you buy it on sideshow and
then i made an addition of 24
much larger fine art prints that i'm
selling at a site called plastic gallery
that's on artsy as well and we are also
giving to genesis
and those are color and black and white
and then there's like 16 other images i
think or 17 but all addition of 24
and once the 24 are sold i'll never make
that kobe ballot
again yeah yeah that's great man that's
great
um all right well we're gonna we can
wrap this up what else do you have any
other
projects that are going on right now
like new books you're working on the
horse book i'm doing
a horse book for for tashan uh you know
i'm
uh getting ready to release the the vr
series
um i have uh i have
my you know other uh
business with the material that i'm
doing and then i am working on an
app which we are going to put out that's
sort of
augmented reality which i've heard about
for four years
and never have been impressed with any
of it and then i saw something that just
blew me away
so we have the developers working on
that and uh
that's all you're gonna say about that
that's what i'm gonna say about that
wait what like i don't even know what
you're talking about but all right yeah
i think it'll blow your mind too okay
man final thing
uh advice to the young creative out
there the young photographer who's just
starting out
or the young activist who's seeking to
make an impact in the world what do you
say to that person
i mean the first thing i'd say is what i
sort of write in every book which is
there is nothing to fear but fear itself
so do not let fear control your life
you're either inferior in faith i wanted
to and i think if you just lean on try
having some faith trust the universe
follow your dreams
you'll start to see results you just got
to have that trust
and the second thing is the young
creative's like please please please
follow your
do your creative don't chase the money
because i
in 35 years have never once woken up and
been like ugh
i gotta go to work today not once i get
paid and made a living doing something i
love to do i wake up every day and be
like oh i'm so excited to go create
that's a it's just a gift yeah it's such
a gift and it's
you know we only get one life well i
don't know might get a bunch but this is
the only life
i have and i definitely don't want to be
780 going like i wish i
always wanted to go here or do this i
always wanted to take pictures
do it life's so short it's precious
you have today forget about all your
yesterdays what are you gonna do today
that's it good talking to you man good
talking thank you man i appreciate it
that was powerful
uh if you're digging on michael you're
easy to find on the internet
uh instagram keep sharing those ice at
stories
michael what's the seven cause someone
you know it's yeah what is that
like someone had michael muller but they
don't post there's like one two posts
they took my name
yeah uh the ice i love the ant-man from
traveling the ice and heat
changed my like if when i get off a
plane after 16 hours
it resets my body all the inflammation
out
um it's phenomenal so right from ice up
to your my neck
two to four minutes into the sauna and
then back in the ice back into the sauna
darren was telling me you always show up
at the workout with like the big cupping
marks on your back
yeah yeah i get a lot of cupping done i
do a lot of i mean
my body i'm like an old beaten up
gladiator so
to keep this 50 year old machine working
it requires a lot of
like tie massage with them walking on me
or you know
and then a lot of like just um
it's almost sadistic what they do to me
but my body's like kevlar it's like
knotted kevlar
yeah but yeah cupping's great except
when they take the cup and go like that
all right well come back and talk to me
again when the when the vr thing is out
in the world we come back and
for sure for sure when the vr is out
when cam's out yeah they'll will
definitely
come back for sure any time this was
great all right thank you brother thank
you everyone
[Music]
you